let's talk about some faulty rules of
writing some old adages on writing that
really don't apply today yay you start
okay well you know you talked about you
know Joseph Campbell's the hero's
journey and it's still and to hear him
speak in these YouTube videos it's a
magical experience it's not to know them
at all but I'm just wondering if as a
teacher there's classes that your
students have taken previously that drum
into you certain adages that really
don't apply I mean we know what what is
it writing is rewriting that that seems
pretty true yeah so something similar to
that and I'm not sure okay
there is a huge business may be an
overly huge business in teaching
screenplay structure a three-act
structure of five extra you know and and
and there are there are III know I know
a fair share of screenwriting gurus who
are at each other's throats all the time
about which structure is the structure
and I'm not saying there's not a
structure I would be in big trouble if I
said there wasn't a structure and that a
story didn't have a beginning a middle
and an end
but this reliance the the the the the
this absolute like like need to follow
any structure map that's out there and
if your and if you don't have a turning
point on page 30 you haven't done it
right or if you're on step 5 of 22 steps
and you're on the wrong step you haven't
done it right or any of this stuff it's
not true
this structure business it's a business
and I can't and you need a diagram to
teach structure and and and and you sell
a diagram and it's very it's it's very
hard to say I have the best diagram
unless you have a diagram right I mean
you need a diagram to sell a diagram
i've told you earlier about my diagram
that ends on page 60 with someone
hanging themselves
it's an emotional diagram it goes like
this it's like page one oh god I can do
this this is gonna be great this is best
story or page ten oh my god I can really
do this everyone who's wrong about me my
parents could go F themselves I'm a
writer on and on emotional and then like
about page twenty you go okay this is
really getting hard and it sorts then
the graph starts going down and down and
then again you get to page sixty and
like I'll never finish this you hang
yourself
it's my structure okay it's an emotional
structure it's an emotional diagram but
wait sorry to interrupt but what happens
after the the hanging man oh well you
you go into despair for a while you put
yourself to bed then you wake up and you
start again and it has a happy ending
okay and at the ending there's big bags
of money all the sex you ever wanted
power that you win right but it's it's
it's obviously tongue-in-cheek and had
to make a point but but but the real
point of it is is that have characters
who you believe in and you believe that
you can write them and that they are in
some sense writing you that they're
coming out of a place of truth for you
put them in the tightest most impossible
situation you can imagine and get them
out of it and know that you have
probably need to do it if you're writing
a screenplay in a hundred to
one hundred and twenty minutes and let
the story flow and there will be natural
points within you doing that where you
will feel that the story needs to go
faster needs to go slower that that that
there needs to meet more drama there
needs to be a moment of rest all of
these things that structure teaches you
and again I'm not saying there isn't a
structure but those structure diagrams
they can be an annus assist you or they
can be a cage hmm they can be an
absolute cage and they can trap you and
there is if you believe that you that
you're a writer you have a natural
storytelling gift that you need to honor
that you need your respect er don't be a
writer
I mean don't don't think that you can
tell a story if you don't feel that you
have a natural storytelling gift and you
can't tell when things are going too
slowly or things are going too fast and
just let it flow and then go back and
see if it's structured right but this is
another thing that will stop people dead
in their tracks over and over again is
your first act is too long who cares who
cares you'll figure that out writing is
rewriting in the rewrite and and and
watch a lot of movies read a lot of
books I am now because of constraints of
time sometime I'm a podcast junkie I
hear the most brilliant stories in
podcasts and stories that have a natural
beginning a middle and an end because
they're true just embrace all of that
embrace the movies that you love take
them to your heart and if you're a
storyteller the story will emerge and it
will merge with a structure let's talk
about sort of that answer it does yeah
yeah and I'm wondering is there anything
about the business that's sort of a
fallacy of these these you know this in
the same vein so you talk about
I'm struggling for what one would be but
where you have this saying that's not
really true okay so again I want to say
that there are a lot of really terrific
development executives out there there
are a lot of great producers I've worked
with some truly great producers I worked
with Scott Rudin on on the Addams Family
for for a couple of years there's never
been a producer who I've worked with who
understands story more deeply than Scott
Rudin and Scott Rudin and when I wrote
and when I wrote that and someone in my
care with my partner Caroline Thompson
one of his greatest gifts was he let us
fail over and over again even finding
the idea for what the movie was going to
be so there are great they're great
development executives there are people
who understand story who will help you
with your story but but there are also
people out there who who are development
executives who never written a script
never made a movie what are they going
to use to come in and and talk to you
about they're gonna use a structure
they're gonna use a structure diagram
they're gonna read the same book you
read and they need that say it have
something to say to you to justify their
jobs they need to have something to say
to you to bring you in and say you know
what as your as your development
executive I'm telling you that your
first act is too long well where are
they getting this information from
they're not getting it from movie god
they're getting it from the same book
that you read and so and so like all
self-reinforcing systems structure
structure guides and structure diagrams
become their own truths that everyone
buys into and pays homage to until
someone doesn't and someone breaks it
all apart and does something that's
innovate
doesn't follow any of the rules and then
those become the rules can I recommend a
podcast since we're talking about
podcast there's a podcast as six parts
you can binge listen to it called inside
psycho and it's about the making of
psycho hmm go to your wherever you get
your podcast and listen to the
development of that movie that classic
movie that is now considered one of the
great movies of all time and where it
started and what the powers-that-be
thought of it and you will see how wrong
people can be and anyone who is who is
holding up your story that you're
telling to a graph and saying it doesn't
fit the graph therefore it's a bad story
watch out they may have a point you're
you may need to get cut to the chase and
get there and maybe the first act is too
long but if they're holding it up to a
graph and that's all they know how to do
you need to look within yourself and say
am i telling the story right not as a
structure guide telling me if I'm
telling the story right I hope that sort
of answers because it almost reminds you
of Jimmy Page smashing a guitar
basically sort of like you know maybe I
wasn't the first one to do that and and
yeah but it is I mean and and again it's
that that allow yourself to fail the
first time it allow yourself to tell the
story the way the story emerges from you
and if you're a storyteller the story
will emerge and you have to believe
you're a storyteller
you